hello welcome to the same plane IM
shahar off the French who told you that
the French okay it's poverty will
opening I don't I don't get it all that
often I mean the rare times i play oh
okay i know that's a little bit that's a
little bit lame but i have no idea about
this opening let's play something simple
the 93 knight c6 tirage is quite a
tricky line so I'm going to go for the
keep it simple method preventing Bishop
g4 maybe 94 now mmm yeah that's that
seems like a like an interesting choice
that looks a little bit if i go to keep
one and he goes like f5 if it looks a
little bit like a painter off or bishop
at five for that matter looks a lot like
a petrov so queen bee three would be the
petrol of like move even though i don't
know what is actually threatens okay I'm
threatening you for here with with queen
bee three but other than that it doesn't
do much how do i get my pieces a bit
more active here
love to trade the dark squared Bishop
that would be able to be nice queen bee
three it probably just goes some goes
King King edge aid I think I'm going to
go here to open up the bishop I was
thinking maybe taking their that put
something to e5 that was my idea try to
play on the somewhat weakened square so
if i take let's do this and now see
what's happening here i was actually
planning 95 but i'm not completely sure
I now that I think of it again yeah
let's do it let's not think about this
for too long c5 is the thing that kind
of worries me here but maybe i have f
three actually you know maybe
and f3 might work on c5 now it does work
i think what disappoint him I goes there
okay um 95 is there some big idea don't
don't quite see it text with em for
years yeah that's interesting so do I
can take this somehow my pieces are not
all that all that grade rating probably
g5 coming up yes I just want to complete
my development here
you
yeah I cannot double unfortunately if I
go 95 doesn't help you might have c5
maybe I should do this here actually 494
I'm covering covering g4 here okay let's
prevent c5 here for for the next couple
of moves oh no you can take me five i
blended in a blunder d5 here but that's
not good okay yeah my king position
doesn't inspire much confidence
oh that doesn't help I mean really not
Jam giving every five I mean blundering
e5 that was hi Bonnie yeah yeah I know
and this is a very stupid position from
the Queen reading ha it was pretty
stupid here ready the way I gave up the
way I give them gave away this game here
I think it was pretty green pretty good
at one point the position top okay white
resign yeah i just lost control there
over this yeah it should be pretty good
for white i think but that's not it's
not easy to play really yeah after that
this is just I just blundered this pawn
I didn't I didn't didn't play this right
here I should go to be 3m that did all
depends on little things here because he
has c/s also opened up his position a
lot so it's very concrete and um yeah
I'm having this this year at least so ha
this is the thing is super active so I'm
probably not winning or anything yeah
he's very active I mean I can barely
move my pieces
any possible bigger edge would have been
would have been reformed yeah I mean
here hmm i have a hard time to believe
that this should be enough compensation
so maybe I maybe I lost too much time
before it's certainly possible ya up to
hear that the engine is somewhat happy a
queen a4 seems to be better looking at
this yeah it's a kind of position where
probably if white is a computer and it
will probably win win the almost every
time because it's so it's so concrete in
an inner game it's not so easy to play
this position and we saw that i
blundered despondent from here this is
just dreadful to play my pieces are not
good at all this is probably a stupid
job but it just it's just a very bad
situation oh no auntie executed as well
I usually win against simmer for an 11
out of 13 squabbit probably one enforcer
yeah if they play some kind of offbeat
ish line that I did I have no general
knowledge about it's always a bit tricky
a map lady form in main lines I usually
have some ideas but yeah yeah maybe I
still should have not taken on d5 yeah
anyway hindsight is 2020 thanks for
watching